what color is that black and blue dress
right there you see what colors that
white and gold one burner never has a
dress caused more controversy since Lady
Gaga's meat gown with your your team
black and blue or team white and gold
these colors don't run we're gonna take
a closer look at this phenomenon and
explain how your eyes might be wires I'm
gonna use mirror there this is hashtag
news when tumblr users swiped uploaded
this image of a dress there's no way she
could have expected it to completely
polarize the entire world but it did
people split up into two camps regarding
the color of the dress they saw on the
picture everyone including many
scientists and smart folks we're a
baffled by this phenomenon but it has
since been revealed that the dress is
indeed black and blue did you get that
grandma it's blue and black how did you
ever see why involve you like when I
think about who I'm like what I told you
why did you make us bleep all that out
you said some really nice I know she's
so sweet I love you grandma regardless
of the fact that it is improving to be a
black and blue dress several
explanations have been released on why
some people might have seen it as white
and bull science like dresses can be
confusing so to help you understand I'm
gonna explain this in the best way I
know how through t-shirt come on gang
okay so I'm outside right now but your
brain sees my white shirt as a little
blue because I'm in the shade but what
if I told you my shirt isn't white it's
blue and your brain just thinks because
I'm outside it's being tinted blue by
the shadows so your brain changes my
blue shirt to white in your eyes don't
believe me actually I never went outside
but you can see this shirt is blue and
you see my blue shirt as blue and it
looks blue because of the indoor
lighting and that's science
if you thought the dress was being lit
by outside light you thought it was
white but it was really just a blue
dress inside the whole time where the
picture was taken is what's confusing
see we can trust our eyes after all they
love you out that's it for hashtag news
we love to make these videos and if you
like watching them please let us know
share them with your friends and your
grandma grandmas need to know what's
going on because they want to stay in
the loop they want something to relate
to you by share subscribe like and
comment we love you guys I'm gonna use
feather and I'm gonna go dress shopping
grandma thank you for watching this
video please stop sending me candy in
the mail I love you I will call you
later